jean françois di meglio président de
l'institut de recherche asia center
bonjour jean françois di miglio merci
d'être avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
alors ce sommet de la zenn peut-il
amener des solutions à la crise en
birmanie oui bonjour c'est peu probable
en réalité d'abord parce que la 0 ces
dix pays donc qui se sont constitué
progressivement depuis 1965 en unions
régionales
c'est un assemblage de pays qui ont des
principes politiques très différents on
voit bien d'ailleurs que la présence du
leader de la junte birmane au milieu de
ses autres leaders qui sont pour
certains élus démocratiquement évoque
les contradictions qui constitue la 0
par ailleurs deux dirigeants des pays de
la zone sont absents le celui des
philippines et celui de thaïlande qui se
sont excusés pour des raisons sanitaires
paulin et donc spécifique pour l'autre
on a donc une représentativité qui est
altérée on est dans un centre qui
s'appelle le siège de l'asian jakarta
mais c'est quoi le siège de l'asian
c'est en fait un personnel politique
très peu nombreux on n'est pas du tout
dans un dispositif qui ressemblerait à
l'onu à l'union européenne
c'est simplement un réceptacle laser
n'est pas constituée en principe
unificateur qui rassemblerait des pays
proches en termes de régime politique et
donc qu'est-ce qu'on va opposer à cette
jeune birman on va simplement lui
opposer effectivement ce qui a été
mentionné le fait qu'on a tiré sur les
populations
plus de 700 victimes comme vous l'avez
évoqué qu'on a emprisonné des personnes
est donc un réel problème politique en
birmanie
jean-françois dit simplement si on sait
que
cette réunion ne sera peut-être pas
favorable justement on fait de trouver
des solutions
quel est l'objectif principal de cette
réunion l'objectif principal déjà c'est
de rappeler quand même que l'ase est là
n'existent ce qui est pas inutile parce
que dans les complexes réorganisation de
la région ces temps ci on a beaucoup de
structures qui se superposent
souvenez-vous que en novembre 2020
ce grand marché organisé d'abord par les
pays de la zale mais auquel la chine la
corée le japon l'australie et la
nouvelle-zélande se sont associés qui
s'appelle le rcp a pris le pas en
quelque sorte sur les institutions
régionales aux portes de la zenn vous
avez un autre dispositif
quels dispositifs anneaux pacifiques
prévues par les états unis
incarnez en particulier par le quad dans
lesquelles se trouvent lane le japon
l'australie et les etats-unis aussi donc
plusieurs dispositifs qui pourraient
faire de l'ombre et une certaine façon
un dispositif régional qui lui a
beaucoup de sens
l'asie du sud-est dit perry d'asus est
mais en face de cette force que
représente la géographie on a des
disparités politiques qui vont
probablement faire de ce sommet un pur
symbole vous parliez tout à l'heure de
la présence du général à la tête de la
junte militaire en birmanie sa présence
qui pose juste mon problème par rapport
à d'autres à d'autres chefs d'état
qu'elle va justement être ses objectifs
à lui ses objectifs à lui c'est déjà de
d'être sûr que tous les pays qui sont là
vont reconnaître son régime comme le
régime légitime en thaïlande
puisque il ya une dissension au sein des
pays de la zone pour savoir si on va
reconnaître soit les opposants puisqu'il
ya une réelle opposition organisée
désormais même si elle est dispersée
entre les différentes provinces de
birmanie
soit on veut reconnaître la possibilité
d'une coalition ou d'une réconciliation
entre les opposants et le régime
soit on va le reconnaître lui tout seul
comme le seul représentant régime
or il faut se souvenir qu'il ya des
élections démocratiques qui sont
naturellement contestée par la junte
mais qui ont été tenues au mois de
novembre 2020 et qui sont le résultat
d'une évolution démocratique de ce pays
depuis maintenant plusieurs années
merci beaucoup france 2 jean-françois di
meglio d'avoir répondu à nos questions à
ce matin sur arte france je rappelle que
vous êtes un président de l'institut de
recherche asia center merci beaucoup